when I think about scheduling it's a
very certain types type of use case it's
it's I want to think of someone that I
want to interact with in real life and I
need I have a high priority to
coordinate with them to make sure it
happens whereas plancast is much more
about Discovery and Serendipity um you
don't think of I'm going to use Plan
cast to make sure that I meet up with a
certain person um at a certain time for
a certain purpose it's more of a in
general I care about these people and
what they're doing because I may want to
join them for things and I will use play
cast on an ongoing basis to to
serendipitously find that when that's
possible um and so I don't really view
it as scheduling so if you post
something like South by Southwest uh
there are hundreds of hundreds of other
people going to that um and so it's
going to show up for more people than a
casual barbecue with only four people
going um so just because of that Dynamic
um you tend to see the stuff that's sort
of larger in scale predominate um but
but the types of original content that's
entered into the system is on all levels
so you have things that are posted
people's personal plans that they have
no one going with them at all you know
they're taking a trip um and they want
to just want to let friends know that
they're going to be out of town uh they
want to tell someone that they're going
to be in New York and then someone might
call them up be like hey I saw you on
plancast you're coming to New York let's
hang out sure um and then on the other
uh end of the spectrum you have things
like conferences and these big things um
so really we're not we're not attempting
to build a tool that addresses one or
the other together in particular um we
definitely love seeing a allot of that
that activity around the big events and
we want to um make that happen as much
as we can but it's not like we're
catering towards that or the the small
small plants well so we want to be
General use we want everyone to have an
interest in using Plan cast whether
they're into a a certain type of event
or or another like if they're into Tech
or they're into music or they're into
sports we want it to be for anything I
think when we started off actually we
thought that there'd be more use around
the small stuff like the really
individual stuff like I'm going to put
up that I'm going to be getting drinks
on a Friday night um and I think because
of that Dynamic that I explained second
ago about the bigger events that has it
surprised us that the bigger stuff has
been what's what we've seen the most of
um but our users have basically told us
that they they get a lot of value out of
that and so we don't want to skew it at
all
um but yeah we we don't we don't think
too much about like how do we uh you
know sort of force upon people how they
should it we just sort of see where
where people find use around it and then
we try to build it out for them so it
works
better um let's talk a couple minutes
about about privacy issues so for
example we're heading out to the tech
crunch on yeah so one of the first
things that I do particularly because I
approach things more from a bb or sales
position as I head out to plast and
check who else is attending that may be
of interest to our business I want to
build
relationships um but in some cases that
you know kind of uh I don't want to say
an infringes on privacy because
everybody's opted in obviously but
there's some privacy issues there you
know not to bring up kind of the most
graphic but if somebody were looking at
my plancast profile they would know that
my wife and kids are home alone this
year y um are you dealing with any of
those privacy issues is something that
you're seeing a ground slow of is your
community talking to about that um we
have so when we started off everything
was public on Plan cast and and before
we introduced any kind of privacy
settings uh we definitely had a lot more
feedback from our users um from the
segment and it was a minority segment
that that wanted to have a greater
control over just who gets their plans
just s of that basic I want my count to
be only accessible by the people that I
pre-approve um since then since we
introduced that functionality we don't
actually hear a lot from our users about
hey I wish um you know things were just
generally more
there's feature requests around you know
certain plans when people post them they
want those to be private um but those
sort of activities just aren't on the
site yet because people opt into not
sharing that stuff yet so it's not as
though we feel as though our users are
putting stuff out there right now that
they're actively concerned will come
back and hurt them um we surprised by on
a percentage basis the number of people
who either decided to keep their plans
open or decide to lock them down yeah I
mean there's a it's a very small
percentage of people who have locked
down their account very small percentage
I mean I can tell you on tungle side
when we went through this do you want to
index or not do you want your profile to
be open to the world we were looking at
about 85 to 90% that's
young yeah yeah I I think there's a lot
to be said for people's understanding
that they sort of live two lives there's
the life stuff that they're going to
share publicly and there's stuff that
they're going to keep private and I
think if you frame Your Service as a by
default public sort of thing um people
are going to get that and they're going
to interact with it as such and they're
not going to
complain um bitterly about not being
able to share certain private things
they're more like likely just a request
functionality that will allow them to do
that so it's not really a problem per se
it's just if if you want to somehow
capture that sort of more private
activity you have to think of ways to to
allow for it um so we don't really view
it as a problem we just view it as a a
sort of uh strategic data issue how do
we you know what's the pros and cons of
of giving more granular controls um and
we don't want to make it more
complicated than it has to be um which
is partly why we kept it open to in
public to start with this whole Space
this sort of uh Geo time social
networking type space you know where are
people going where are they right now
for what uh we're at very much the early
stages of it um and so we don't really
view ourselves as actively competitive
with one any one other player um
everyone's sort of doing their own piece
on it and um there are synergies lots of
different ideas in terms of how
synergies can come about um you know you
got the checking guys like Forest square
and goala um which is all about where
you right now and and uh tracking sort
of your footprint through life um
there's us that's sort of the Forward
Thinking uh you know discovering things
that people are doing before it actually
happens uh there's the calendar guys
that have a lot of data that we kind of
want but it's it's not in the right kind
of context um and also there's a lot of
data and calendars that people don't
want to share publicly so it's not a one
to one about that context for a
second um well so people use calendars
because they want to remember things
primarily um and they want to think if
they want to add something to their
their schedule they got to make sure
that they're not going to have a
conflict um and when they want to you
know uh just sort of recall uh the sort
of things that they have done in the
past they can sort of look it up um it's
not something they go to to discover
something new it's it's something to go
to to remember something that was
already there all right so let me give
you some new context just in terms of
here is is a is a bridge that I see so
one of the features that we introduce
recently is this idea of making an event
public right so if you were to go to my
tongle me page today you would see this
week at the top that I'm in San
Francisco couple reasons for that the
first is if you're coming to my tongle
me page to book a meeting with me no
sense in Booking with me in Montreal
Toronto because I'm on
the um the second is that I can kind of
push that out to my social scen I guess
what I would say we don't offer more
granular detail than that reference you
guys um but that's kind of there's a
certain amount of collaboration that can
take place there right so when you're
saying it's it's kind of a backward
looking you know I want to remember
where I was or what I was doing as a
reference point that's exactly what
we're talking about when we transition
manage go
forward yeah yeah I'm really talking
about calendars traditionally I think
calendars can serve a starting point for
a lot of advanced functionality social
functionality MH um you know I think
Google deserves some credit for doing a
little bit when it comes to
experimenting with public versus private
entries and calendars and and trying to
make that sort of open up your calendar
to more public consumption um but they
didn't really take it very far um and so
it leaves sort of the challenge up to
people like us to figure out what can we
do to innovate around how people use
their calendars um I mean we we often
call ourselves sort of a social calendar
um even though we're not looking to
replace in any way you know Google
Calendar or your outlook um um it's a
different sort of experience that we
want to provide for people but there's
there's natural tie-ins the calendars
that you you already
use well so there's a question that I
think the the primary question we have
to ask ourselves is the type of product
are we building that we're building is
it um does it have the potential to
apply to people all over is it a
mainstream uh type of product if people
in Middle America in Europe outside the
valley um were to encounter it uh and to
start use it would they actually find
Value out of it or would it be sort of
just like oh this seems good for Tech
events but nothing else um I think that
question to me is just fairly obvious um
everyone everywhere likes to go do
things with people so um whether is
there a cultural barrier there in terms
of saying you know it's not sometimes
you get out ahead of the curve right and
so you definitely you've seen adoption
of the product without question um but
the tendency to put out where I'm going
to be in public is something new to
people right we see it in our business
too how prepared are you and a lot of it
generation right as remove kind of into
Senior Management SE Su much more
inclined to publish
lar yeah do you see that kind of
cultural to call um I'm not so concerned
about cultural barriers or generational
barriers I'm more just concerned about
the the general adoption curve of new
technologies so when you release
something that's new and it's it's not
something that already has an example so
I'm not I'm not releasing another
toaster you know people mainstream
people don't know what a plan cast is um
it's going to take time for us to get
enough adoption in the early adopter
segments um and then sort of the the
more uh I guess uh experimental
mainstream segments uh before sort of a
normal American normal European will be
like oh plancast I use that um just
because people look to others in terms
of what they want to use and um they
just require different education levels
uh so it's it's a matter of just uh
marketing and um moving up the adoption
curve for us uh we we don't view it as a
we're going to exhaust a certain segment
and then we're not going to have any
more people to Market to um because like
I said I think what the the the main
value we're trying to Pro provide
applies anywhere unless if you're
someone who just doesn't like to go out
and do stuff then it's not for you but
um there are tons of people in in
different societies that in different
parts of society that that do want to do
that so but the you've also got um you
know the 800 pound gorilla being
Facebook is getting people used to the
concept of sharing right whether it's
sharing pictures I mean LinkedIn has
taught people are sharing contacts and
sharing personal information and so I'm
certainly sorry to add one of the things
we were there to talk to them about was
events right I mean certainly there's
been enough whisper about an email
application being built there right
they've got your contacts got an event
component a calar program well that's
said and they're swirling around the
space is it something that you consider
is it something that you care about
sorry D no it's cool yeah I I definitely
care about it um I I imagine they're
thinking about all these things they're
thinking about calendars they're
thinking about they're aware of us
they're aware of you guys they're
thinking about word processors I'm sure
um you know I think Facebook actually
tends to look up at Google versus more
down I mean I'm sure looking they're
both looking both ways but they're
trying to think of how do they become
the next Google um and you know you
could sort of sit around and sort of
think okay well Facebook will figure out
the best way to do all these things but
I actually think U you know the bigger
that Facebook gets um even though
they're still extremely
Innovative they still have path
dependency on their their their current
product people understand them and
understand using them in a certain way
um they understand themselves in a
certain way so you can't really sit
around and Sort of hope that they create
the best version of a product that will
that will serve Us in the ways we're
discussed
um so I I put my money on uh you know a
startup coming up with much more
innovative solutions here than than a
Facebook or a Google um they may try to
emulate it but uh they just don't have
sort of the the focus or the uh sort of
the the heart to to Really
execute um on these sort of problems as
their primary
concern yeah I mean they have lots of
things they have to worry about and so
um who knows whether you're sort of uh
in the middle of the road of what
they're going to drive down or not if
you are then that's too bad um or it may
just it may just valid validate your
Market I mean so Twitter for example was
uh when when they just start started to
hit it big uh they're right in the
sights of Facebook and if anything
Facebook I think validated what they
were doing uh didn't kill them
so if that could happen to any of our
startups then good for us right it's you
know we say something we we talk about
that regularly in our offices we see as
an example Google releasing new product
new feuture functions so you know
increasingly they're encroaching on what
we're doing at the same time it's just
validation it educate the market for you
guys rather ride their and have to
people will taste what it's like and say
okay well I got a little bit of this
from Google because they introduced it
into my gcal experience but now that
I've tried it it doesn't quite work the
way I wanted to oh there's this tungle
thing I could use it's even better how
about I use that sure um it's
interesting I mean I think just several
years ago people thought of you know why
would you do X startup idea because
Google's just going to do it right no
one really says that these days I think
because we've seen Google try to go
outside the core competency several
times uh and just not be that killer
sort of force that people feared that it
would be and so I think the same thing
applies to you know Facebook it's sort
like we're at this period of time where
people think oh well Facebook could do
it um and like yeah they could but
doesn't mean they will